what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation the time has come to enter the ring
for creed 3. I am joined by the guy who watched
The Last of Us with him wah he only watched
Creed One and Two For the First Time like
yesterday right that's right yeah yeah he's
not in this let's not supposed to be mindful
this is Andrew Gordon eight or seven eleven
thanks for being back here you little buff
man over here are you excited I'm very pumped
I loved Creed one and two so I'm really looking
forward to this one he's the only one who
hasn't seen Creed 3 in the theaters John I
didn't know until last week he saw this in
the theaters apparently I don't ask people
to not go to the theaters I take that burden
on myself if I want to do a movie reaction
here and I got really lucky with this guy
having that secret one or two so here we are
guys you know what to do ding ding that like
button I understood that reference also full-length
stretch and watch songs where you sync up
with your own copy of Crete three available
for super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
thank you to all who have joined and we cover
so many things over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs included
enough beating around the bush let's see what
all the hype is about oh my God laughs
try not to laugh at that but I couldn't open
you gotta he understood
[Music]
oh I see anime in the background apparently
Michael B Jordan wanted to make sure they
put anime because of this big thing in his
childhood [Music] pretty sure that's not root
too there's the root yeah there's my boy Naruto
[Music] oh that must be young Jonathan Majors
what's wrong without you come on bro
it is not safe to be in a car with Jonathan
Majors oh God
that should be expecting this
ooh I love that lighting transition from yellow
to like dark Beyond blue
how y'all doing today
got plenty of time for that trust that dude
really does look like a young Jonathan major
I was thinking that yeah
dude they go way back yeah
you mean you don't have one not that I know
of
you check me whoa that's a cool shot
damn damn and that hurt me
good transition but when you playing
nicely I got some too so worried they're gonna
get pulled over with that gun it's original
all that that is not a good diet for being
a boxer yes like the exact opposite oh let
me do it oh I'm supposed to know
oh a little Donny
wow that was a cool transition this guy's
got a grip on transitions rival and what krita
said Pretty Ricky conlon I thought he retired
impressive combo is this is rematch yeah I
guess so yeah
the moment is getting to Creed here [Applause]
don't be caught in the past man [Applause]
nice nice found an opener
damn dude these are cool shots dude I'm really
impressed with his Direction so far but you're
smiling for a dog he over there beating you
worse than last time like it's something I
missed [Applause]
holy crap
ouch awesome damn
whoa wow oh knock out from the body oh my
God there is so much Exquisite style to the
fighting [Applause] what a chest without a
dream damn in round two on the rematch that's
crazy you have no more enemies now Donnie
it's so cute
laughs
that's a good dad
that's cool they got a studio in their house
Shack jersey in the background yes I know
you know that who he is yeah Kazam
take that off oh I see what you're trying
to do trying to get me naked oh no Mom yes
okay I just I have like about 15 minutes
a dude in three just watching you two [Laughter]
we need a new badge you've
I guess he's gonna fight Ivan Drago I mean
uh Victor Victor yeah you gotta be ready to
fight dragon in four weeks wow we know you
got power but it's not always about how hard
you can hit it's about control Focus how hard
you can get back yeah the quote it's about
how hard you can get hit and keep moving forward
how much you can take and keep moving forward
that's how winning is done Jacob's got a bigger
name that's true but Felix got the belt I
don't care if they don't like it whoa tell
Dragon to call me as a nice vehicle it's worth
at least thirty thousand dollars J yeah times
ten yo remember me huh come a long way from
bummer rides from your mom damn
time to get some grip thank you thank you
Adonis does not watch what he eats hey you
do not get a boxer's body like this I know
he's in retirement but still the shape he's
in yeah road trip few times you did where'd
you send them I'm crazy
ah she's still looking better yeah she's still
there same house but I never got him how dare
she yeah that wasn't cool but I understand
why he'll be your big head back up remember
that
you got work I got plans what are these plans
what's the plan same program last time you
saw me
I want to be champ
you're still in the box hey I know I've been
away a long time although I kept myself in
shape you know I got some moves you ain't
seen yet yeah doesn't believe all right come
by the gym get you set up with Duke all right
then he is a great actor though Jonathan Majors
yeah he is he's great
oh my goodness how you feeling mama you good
it'd be better if my son showed up on time
for dinner uh sorry I just got caught up with
an old friend that you hid the letters from
mm-hmm
do you think they're gonna kill her off the
daughter I have a daughter or not uh I was
it's in the back of my head I'm thinking that
could happen and I really am fine I promise
you I am not going to have another stroke
tonight oh oh what's up with you yeah where
were you tea just ran into this guy named
Dave
trigger word who's he
he's a beast I'm just trying to give him a
break isn't that what we do anyway no this
ain't a YMCA look around dude you see anybody
lining up and getting the ring with Felix
he's gonna no yeah where Duke's gonna take
care of you we back to Ground Zero James gotta
start somewhere right
nice there's like a Lost Child thing about
Jonathan Major's expression Felix me Damien
you're gonna spawn with you you still remember
how to do that yeah I he probably shouldn't
have said that antagonistic thing towards
him
really in class in front of the teacher whoa
whoa
has your daughter punched her in the face
[Laughter]
what if she's someplace she's supposed to
be safe and she's not she won't know how to
protect herself get her a gun [Music] I know
that you think that you are protecting her
baby but she has got to know why she wants
to fight not just how to do it and the only
solution to every problem is not a punch in
the face yeah you're right and sometimes it
is that Damien okay I see you made it all
right oh yeah I just asked him well where
did black family live at tomorrow
hmm nice to meet you nice to meet you she
says YouTube I remember when I was first learning
sign language was a little daunting how long
have you known each other the old back way
back it was like brothers shared a room for
two years at the gym yeah something like that
I'm gonna get her to bed okay see you Tuesday
ketchup oh invite him to the label party I
heard that I'm invited to the labor party
thank you so much for coming yeah no doubt
my pleasure to meet you so happy Tessa Thompson's
getting this much screen time maybe I can
make myself clear
I want a title shot damn it don't work like
that feeling so cold what he got to lose what
you got to lose what you think I could just
snap my fingers and make you a contender overnight
ain't that what happened to you
it's like but my last name's Creed yeah look
all I'm saying bro Apollo Creed could take
a chance on something wow that's so cool why
can't you
like I say you know you asked me to fight
Felix for real yeah heavyweight champion of
the world with their whole lives for a shot
like that and he's not even a pro yeah
yeah why does it look like you're sucking
so considerated I love this shot it's really
interesting the purpose that Damien serves
as like a way to confront his past keep
that's what I'm talking about get your Championship
shot
yo [Applause]
hey what's going on out here okay use your
head leave all that other mess outside I told
you who I wanted oh it's just getting dark
I told you right away it was a mistake I got
it you don't you let him come in here with
a chip on his shoulder that's exactly but
don't get quiet now dookie
damn I'm really liking this a lot feels just
different yeah very different yeah I mean
I'm definitely missing Rocky but I mean it's
it's under it's still it's really I haven't
even thought about rookie that's funny
oh [__] see that on the mirror what did
it say on the mirror I didn't see it Curry
defeats soprino oh oh okay [Music]
his home looks like Rocky's from the first
movie actually yeah well I was gonna say it
looks more like uh donis's
[Music]
oh man
it's interesting like the movie Cuts back
and forth between the future he's trying to
stay on the path there but then he's got this
pass that's kind of catching up to him that
he hasn't resolved don't worry about them
so many other things in here should be looking
at all right for you bro yeah congrats boy
I'm gonna make sure that's the fight of the
year
why would you say that in front of him yeah
seriously yeah I guess that's what y'all do
look at him over here get his Don King on
minus thank God that's a Rocky 5 reference
curious what happened with you too oh you
wanna know how I got locked up yeah uh
got into a fight I have a few priors pulled
gun that didn't pop off I ain't saying do
they deserve it but it was dude his name was
Leon the rest of it we don't leave it down
here to tell you you already said this much
yeah
whoa what oh
no we're not canceling anything oh my God
someone has to fight Felix I know I know I
know but we'll figure it out do not move the
date it on oh wow I was so unexpected I know
where the hell did I come from about just
finding another fight I know and I understand
your frustrations I really do so what are
you gonna do maybe two other contenders outside
of Drago this is Ortiz Nana spirino he's recovering
from his last fight okay so then who you know
who you know God damn well who Rocky yeah
what do you have in mind he wants you to fight
dang Dame Damien ain't a boxer he's fighting
the world he's trying to hurt people no I
don't like it I think it'd be a circus what
he means is he's gonna put on a show exactly
no it's not what we promised okay I understand
but if it was me I do it you think damn had
anything to do with that guy attacking Drago
or was that just random I hope for either
answer just let your boy know I'm gonna beat
his ass when I'm in that ring all I want you
to do it's your job I love this because you
can't really tell if Adonis is making this
decision because it's best for the show or
if it's just a personal you know uh I feel
like it I feel like it's a bit of both because
he knows they can't wait six months but he
feels like he still owes him the future of
Two fighters hangs in the balance Creed Athletics
is promoting the most surprising fight of
the year will it be a Cinderella story or
another notch on the Champion's belt is I
want oh Staple Center nice sorry crypto.com
Arena hate that name are you anti-American
no I just hate that name I like Staple Center
better [Music]
dude they really do a good job really making
you feel every punch yeah especially helps
when you have headphones I'm sorry what'd
you say good in here I know my ears are ringing
from the punch no seriously look
look lighter thank you you ain't gotta thank
me Dan this is a fascinating story yeah it
is it really is actually yeah I don't know
the children's may look like way more cut
and dry like I'm out for you Creed this is
so much more layered and complex wow love
it this is Michael B Jordan's very first film
he's directed right yeah because it doesn't
feel like it feels like he's an amateur pro
at this whoa that is cool
oh my goodness it's like a Day of the Dead
thing Dia de los Muertos
man the theatrics of this is the former Golden
Gloves Champion
that's how Greg and I look right now I look
like that when I shave my body
I want to remind you protect yourself at all
times
I love the focus of the audio just like zones
out the crowd yeah [Applause] what's up
shouldn't be rooting for any of them jab there
but Anderson showing good movement whoa
ouch [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] oh he's just going after that shoulder
in that arm smart
he may have some tricks in his back
[Music] there he didn't get called on it oh
LBC is that yep damn he is lethal who's that
look at his eyes man
come on
oh come on
I don't think it's gonna matter this is a
Fight for Your Life oh
[__] not to fight any of us expect
a God damn
good this is dangerous Anderson's swinging
oh
my goodness
oh later knock out
that's the first time I cut to the mom in
this fight huh uh a second time second time
yeah because she was having trouble with taking
her medication [Music]
[Music] that's why the mom hit the letters
oh my God Felix he's probably gonna be paralyzed
for life now no I'm already ain't no making
nothing right ain't no Duke nothing like a
fix no I can't he did some illegal moves though
man is the word illegal like that was the
worst I mean he did some work moves that are
like all right I mean yeah I mean he got some
point deductions you need him in that album
yeah [Music]
letters for you
oh dear Donny I'm going to kill you one day
they're from Damien
oh okay Foreman Muhammad Ali kept these from
me you didn't suspect that already I thought
you did I know I thought we'd expect the second
do you know what we went through I know who
that man was the two of you beat up then you
know Damien had my back before you even knew
who I was Dame treated me more like family
than your two kids ever did in this house
and you took that away from me none of this
would have happened if it wasn't for you whoa
you're absolutely right
none of it she's gonna have a stroke On Cue
it may have been a time when Damien had your
back
he's manipulating
oh that letter says I'm coming for you oh
is it the guy who uh broke Victor's uh hand
yeah so yeah I was gonna say that was too
rant that was too damn random to happen I
suspected it but I was like he could he doesn't
have the money to hire a guy because yeah
that's the only thing I threw a threw a wrench
in that you've been playing me this whole
time I brought you into my home bro you met
my family the dark side gonna come out no
when I got locked up I leave when I came home
yeah bro I needed you look around bro run
away run away as to what I think you're still
good at baby Creed oh oh call them baby crude
come on man this title oh this I'm coming
for it all and what's that supposed to mean
you threatening me oh God damn it dude help
yourself up for once she already feel
damn oh [__] dude you trying to feel sorry
for me or something I don't want to feel sorry
for you I want to understand you I want to
know what is going on I don't want to talk
about anything I've been trying to forget
it it's Dad leave it leave it let it ride
I'm talking about that [__] no more
Heaven is her seeing you like this
do you understand I was such a well-acted
scene I know this one's there was so so much
darker than the previous ones just a little
bit
you know it's a closed set when you leave
a Rolls-Royce with your window halfway down
visiting world of the spot yeah oh okay so
the guy abused physically abused them but
you know what it is huh
damn oh that sucks
that that is complicated as [__] yeah
it's not the way it looks you better get here
right away mom had another stroke oh no I
can't remember every time I say goodbye I'm
sorry
oh I think this is his fault he was so mad
come knock everybody out what
just like your father
that's why he fought so hard you know that
right you don't have to do that you can find
another way
I was angry I was so angry when you left me
Apollo whoa did you leave me alone
I've done this
his name wow he saved me Apollo
he helped me to forgive you
[Music]
time I see this in a movie it hits me 20 times
harder understandable you have got to try
to forgive yourself so that you can begin
to believe that you deserve the life that
you have
you have to let him destroy everything you've
built Jesus he's not gonna stop then you make
him there's only one way the damn's gonna
listen you gotta pound his face if that's
what you gotta do then oh man oh [__]
I was not expecting that answer there's one
thing I want you to do for me when when the
one and only Adonis Creed is sitting right
next to me Stephen A Smith wow he's on first
take I know you watch the show every morning
yeah definitely he questions Amanda he talks
about your family he talks about how you can't
be trusted and that you don't run out on your
boat no no no wait dude let me just hold on
hold on we got a call come in uh I'm just
telling everybody who you really are are you
running our own family this ain't the way
to handle it oh bad news bro this live so
I mean this is how we gonna handle it now
I love how they verified it was him through
the phone I know everybody else knew it hey
uh Apollo Creed will be shame God damn it
all right I challenge you for the heavyweight
championship of the world oh my God y'all
heard it here first I know I can't wait I
didn't see that coming
trading monsters
Greg and I actually hit the gym right before
we watched this we wanted to get in character
[Applause] you don't got it no more he retired
he probably won't even make weight and remind
me how many concussions have you had reminds
me when his dad said the same thing to uh
Rocky and Rocky Balboa we can't turn back
the clock we can't hide all your flaws but
we can't make them strips
[Music] [Applause] um damn's working out in
public
oh we got the vest on that thing is heavy
hello that would be so scary partner yeah
seriously even with that head gear on you
gotta block out everything and be in the moment
not to pass not the future right now it's
gonna be a mental battle as well as a physical
for him
good enough to be to you what I did not see
this go back surely I didn't either
he's not in boxing shape anymore
heart soul it crumbs
[Music]
back get back
Russian twists
oh look Howard shape these guys are what's
the food they eat sure all this fries
[Music] I hope he punches that tree down oh
God oh damn
dude I would have loved to see if this was
their actual training regimen for the movie
oh my God
goals one day they can see each other that's
the only person he's battling the other guy
is in the way I get it it's a reference to
Creed one [Music]
I love it eat it up [Applause] foreign [Applause]
oh my God this fight's going to be insane
[Applause] dude he is in Insanity shape one
of his abs equals my bicep
Maybe
oh zoning at the audio again
this symbolism on those gloves kind of look
like something from Naruto actually
it's gonna be
a mental battle [Music]
damn there's great camera work in this yeah
whoa
whoa [Applause]
nicely done [Music] I'll see you in a minute
don't worry I'll be right back that was great
let's see if Adonis can find his answers damn
the camera work is phenomenal stop running
Tony
give him up keep them up you got old man can't
beat me heads up
oh [__] whoa
[Applause] that was sick are they hit each
other in their clothes that was that was awesome
that was awesome I do see in just alone the
way the camera work is and capturing the punches
that I think it's in my anime Flare from it
wow
that's interesting
[Music] that is so wow what what
oh even the music choice
oh
dude the visual style and the artistic choices
brilliant bold
[Music] oh boy oh boy
[Music] wow transitioned into a POV yeah the
cinematography is amazing
wow [Music] oh wow what a transition with
everyone in the crowd too wow I've never seen
anything like that in Rocky or Creed that
was crazy I need you to start fighting go
out there and do
it you know I wore a Naruto shirt because
I heard he's a Naruto fan but this fight reminds
me of like these two characters from their
Sasuke and Naruto
thank you [Applause] what the [__] man
[Applause] oh
damn
you all right you all right
hmm
come on
oh nice [__] all right
this down
the rocky sprinkled in yeah
I'm sorry all those years
never checked up on you that's on me
we were just
kids bro didn't need to fight him in order
to get him to listen
you get a handshake
that's how we do it that was better [Music]
I
always wanted to be a baseball player that's
exactly what he was thinking
all right let's get to the mid credit scene
the post-credits I don't know oh Ryan cougar
wrote the story out okay cool uh Sylvester
Stallone Sylvester Stallone loves you dude
wiggler well [__] let's talk about it
Andy all right guys well everything was good
about that movie except for Jonathan majors
and Michael B Jordan's Direction other than
that the rest of the movie was good [Music]
I wonder whose honest opinion is that that
would be funny to hear um no I like I really
I really liked it I wanna there's I there's
some cons that I think well my subjective
cons I know this franchise I've seen every
one of them I grew up especially on the rocky
films and weirdly I didn't and I heard a few
people say that they they would wonder where
Rocky is and I wasn't really thinking about
that until a certain point in the movie I
know exactly what you're talking about what
point what point was it do you think I'd say
like once after the mother passed and then
we started ramping up into the training montage
yeah is that when you were kind of that's
when I was like how come there's no like I
think a question I don't even need Rocky to
still show up in this movie just like just
a mention of him kind of thing right and one
mention of what's going on with Rocky I will
say this look I I would have loved full for
Sylvester Stallone to be in this film thank
you Irwin Winkler is that he said or is it
Irvin whatever we don't need to respect Winkler
we just watch the movie yeah whatever the
case I I would have loved for Sylvester to
be in the film or rocky rather having said
that I thought Creed 2 really wrapped up Rocky's
story very beautifully so I understand I mean
I don't understand what ever happened behind
the scenes but I mean I get it but I agree
with you I would have appreciated it just
just a mention or a comment would have been
nice but I mean there were definitely points
where I was just thinking about him not saying
like I wish he was here I could I do but you
know what I mean like I it wasn't affecting
the storyline is what I was trying to say
but I just would have loved to have been there
because I love Rocky so I mean from that perspective
but overall I really did enjoy this movie
I you know everyone's always gonna ask well
is it the best of the Creed films you know
that's all subjective uh I definitely would
say the first one is still probably my favorite
but I still really enjoyed this I was really
impressed with Michael B Jordan I mean this
is his film debut behind the you know directing
so I was really impressed there were a lot
of artistic stylistic choices when it came
to a cinematography perspective and there
were a lot of well-acted scenes I mean the
scenes with him and Tessa Thompson with Bianca
I mean those scenes were extremely not only
were they just well acted but I thought too
from a story perspective which Ryan cooler
and whoever the other writers were a great
job I thought they did just it just laid the
foundation of hey he really leans on Bianca
like she is his Rock like whenever he's lost
like I mean even you know when he's enjoying
life and doing it he obviously you know she
she's his his wife and he loves her and all
that but when he's down and the chips are
down for him like she is his Rock and I love
how they really like hammered that through
throughout the film and come on Rock come
on you set me a [__] oh Jesus Christ that's
true that wasn't even trying to make that
fun but no it's a good that's a good uh astute
observation my friend but I thought Tessa
I mean obviously look we'll get into Jonathan
majors and Michael B Jordan their performances
were terrific in this film but I think Tessa
Thompson like I was not expecting you made
the comment through uh during the reaction
like I wasn't expect I knew she was going
to be in the film I wasn't expecting the role
to be as big as it was but I'm glad it was
because she was fantastic and I really like
her character and just in general from the
first two films so I'm glad they expanded
upon it expanded upon her role rather but
and fleshed her out a little bit more with
in the relationship she has with uh Adonis
but yeah no I Jonathan Majors look regardless
of what we think about what's going on um
in his personal life acting wise he is fantastic
in this I love the way they flesh out his
character and again in the first two films
I mean look when it comes to Pretty Ricky
conlon we don't really know too much about
his backstory other than he's about to retire
so you don't get too much in depth with his
character when it comes to Victor Drago we
obviously know the history of with his dad
and and Rocky and Rocky 4 so we lay it's more
of a foundation there and just The Fallout
of what's happened from that film so again
you get a little bit into his backstory but
obviously with Dave with Dame you get way
more and I really thought it was compelled
like the first two thirds of this film I loved
what they said I mean this was a really dark
dramatic character study and I thought it
was very well done and then it really switched
up a little bit but I mean again the first
two thirds of this film chef's kiss it was
fantastic which is him what'd you think I
I agree with everything you said we should
talk about the Jonathan major situation [Laughter]
yeah um no no I I do agree with what you said
like I I the reason I didn't think about Rocky
until you said something in the in the movie
and and right but I was so into the dark Drama
character study and how nuanced that was and
what a complicated situation that must be
like it really it was really interesting to
see a man like Adonis Creed seem so focused
then like this man Adonis Creed who had this
this all this fortune and success and this
and and a newly established Legacy that's
outside of the name Apollo Creed and just
trying to keep moving forward but then having
this this chip on his back this thing that
is not only just oh I have an unresolved thing
with a former person it's that person brings
back all kinds of memories of a whole life
that he had that is catching up to him and
that darkness that he's been just trying to
push away and I love the idea of how the what
Adonis has to deal with is he needs to just
not just confront his feelings but learn some
like vulnerability like that's such a big
part of the movie is I need to learn to talk
about my feelings or else the it's going to
consume me and it's going to come out of me
and it's going to cause me to make some bad
decisions so that's why I loved the moment
when he does decide to let Dame fight the
champion because it does have me in the audience
going is this for best for the show or is
this best because or is he just doing this
because it's a it's a personal thing he's
getting his feelings are getting too involved
in the matter so I really love that and I
think Jonathan majors in him having having
such a complicated passive and I love how
it wasn't just Jonathan Majors as uh you know
young Dame shot the guy I love how they didn't
go down with that yeah he was just protecting
him you know absolutely and that makes it
even more complicated for the fact that Adonis
just didn't try to visit him or anything like
that so the guilt that would weigh over him
over such a thing makes a lot of sense but
you know bringing it back to the what I loved
about the ending moments was it brought it
back to what made those first two thirds great
and like don't get me wrong I think the final
fight is is impressively shot great like that
final fight was uh I think the final fight
is especially as a fan of of the Rocky movies
which usually have especially by the time
we got to Rocky of Balboa they get to a moment
where like you feel like you're just watching
a real boxing matches yeah and and often times
like as theatrical as they are the amount
of like head counts they get the a big part
of the of the experience I think of Rocky
in the Korean movies is getting to that final
fight where you feel like you're in your protagonist
shoes and every time they get hit you feel
the hit you know and and I thought what Michael
B Jordan decided to do with going with a with
a much more expressive route that was clearly
riffing on a lot of the um animation influences
that he grew up on and there are part like
I heard what I heard before was that he was
a big fan of of Naruto so or something about
I heard something about Naruto while he was
promoting this and so I was like today honor
whatever the hell was going out there and
there was a fight and there is a thing in
the fight especially when they're seeing like
the childhood versions of themselves because
this is dealing so much with unresolved past
their children and reminds me of a couple
of the characters in there it's a great show
by the way I still haven't finished it but
it's a great show but still it's forever episodes
but it's but uh but I'm very very deep into
it I only got like 50 more to 100 episodes
ago I'm like like a thousand episodes in or
something it's a it's a great show um so yeah
I thought that was excellent uh but the the
Bane the main criticism I have is that after
the the mom dies and around the time when
the mom was even dying it started feeling
like we're moving through this a little quick
I know it was very emotional for you understandably
why um I I get it no jokes will be made about
that don't worry I'll watch myself on that
I will not make fun of your traumatic past
thank you appreciate it because I'm a good
guy so I will not go there even though I can
relate so I feel like that kind of gives me
a pass where we could make a dark joke
but I don't see an opening here
but anyway it does first it's like this own
complex drama of these two and this big manipulation
game where yeah there's a there's this Ferocious
Beast and then Jonathan major is given his
excellent performance but I love the complexities
of them and then suddenly it becomes we're
going to do a really short Rocky movie by
the beat you know of like I'm gonna fight
you in the ring let's go and then it just
like we start moving through it so quick to
the point where as impressive visually as
I thought the fight was it did not give me
as a viewer like there were some exciting
moments for sure and I wasn't I was in awe
of how it looked it did not personally give
me the experience the catharsis experience
that you usually get in the Rocky and Creed
movies by the time you get to that final fight
you know what I'm talking about so I I don't
know if you had it I was more like I'm very
appreciative of what I'm watching and I'm
really an admiration of it it looks great
and this is different and cool about it emotionally
I wasn't as connected to that fight only because
of how I felt like we just started I really
feel like there was like a half hour that
was missing here I I was thinking like this
film really could have benefited from another
20 to 30 minutes would have really made a
again I I still was beyond impressed the artistic
visual choices like where they drowned out
the entire crowd and the audio was gone and
you just had that that background score and
we were just hearing you know the the punches
and it felt like it was just one-on-one them
nobody else there like I'd never seen that
in a Creed or an Iraqi film I thought that
was stylistically a very interesting and incredible
Choice by Michael B Jordan I was I was enjoying
what I was watching but to agree with what
you're saying it just it just really felt
like we rushed to that point from right after
the mother passed away and it's it's not like
a major criticism it's just like again you
want to get that that full feel of what you
feel when you normally watch a Rocky film
or a Creed film when we get to that final
fight and again visually we were enjoying
what we were watching was a great fight scene
for sure it's just kind of time jumped through
a lot it's just it's just like yeah and now
we're in the ring and yeah when so much of
the stakes were were kind of dependent on
he Adonis hasn't been fighting for years three
years I think they said right he's been yeah
like he's been out of it and um but I still
really appreciate like that really those first
two thirds are just so strong to me it was
unbelievable I love those first two thirds
and I like the last third it is where I would
say because those first two thirds were I
wasn't thinking about Rockets I'm like this
is a very cool direction to take it where
it feels very personal and intimate and it's
like the movie has heart but not heart in
the way of how you normally associate heart
for the rocky franchise like there's hard
in the sense of you got the family and you
got the support but they really lean more
into the the traumatic dark wounds that these
characters have and I appreciated them going
down that route because it it made the the
reason for fighting feel very different and
and I love the ending notes as well so yeah
I mean I think like all the performances are
great I think their direction is great I think
the music is good uh I I think see the thing
is I'm not I'm not sliding with the part that's
missing like it would have made that finale
so much better it's added to it because it's
just like we're doing we're like it's like
a Ryan coogler movie and then suddenly it's
just like a [__] speed through this Rocky
movie where there were things that were there
could have been more moments that you really
felt for it in the build up and and I think
I feel like probably there was a longer cut
and Michael B Jordan was forced to cut it
down because the movie's already bordering
on two hours yeah no I mean and I remember
thinking the first two thirds like wow this
is so different from anything I've seen in
a Creed or a Rocky film it but I was loving
it because it was so compelling what they
were doing and then it just jumped right into
a Rocky film which is fine you can go into
a I mean it's in the rocket franchise so I
mean I get it but from what we had gotten
in the first two thirds to then jumping right
into that but rushing into it I agree with
you I feel like there was something that was
and again we're not saying we didn't we we
loved this movie but I think like had you
had what Greg is talking about it would have
made a good movie a phenomenal phenomenal
movie um so I yeah I get it and I was thinking
the same thing as it was unfolding I was like
wow we are really going into this quickly
here at the end because again the first two
thirds I I I really was not expect I mean
I'd seen the trailers so I mean I knew a little
bit about what to expect but I just was not
expecting like a deep complex dramatic character
study what we were getting and it was just
so interesting and well told and like you
said earlier too I was so glad when um Dame
pulled that gun I'm so glad they didn't actually
go the route of him shooting just more of
just defending his friend and just like get
off of him type thing and was just wrong situate
bad timing wrong situation when the cops pulled
up and yeah it just adds a different type
of layer to the character where you just you
even though the character is is is a beast
or John the majors character of Dame is is
a total beast and can be a little bit of a
dick at times you really feel you know empathetic
or sympathetic towards the character for what
happened because again he was just defending
his friend yeah and then obviously you know
there's the history of well Adonis didn't
visit him at all and didn't write him back
obviously that was obviously his mom hit the
letters from him but I mean yeah there was
a lot of baggage there and again I just thought
the way the characters for the most part were
fleshed out and the backstory is just it was
really well done I love seeing everything
with Amara as well yes I'm really glad they
they lean more into that relationship and
yeah having that because you know especially
if you compare to like a Rocky and Adrian
which rarely goes to like Rocky Force when
they went through Rocky three and four they
go through some dark [__] they always
have like a fight in something but but it
never goes that dark where it's like this
is some real dark [__] that they're going
through you know and I loved I loved the chemistry
and the and the fleshing out of the relationship
and and I really appreciate as the as a Cree
trilogy how much of an evolution like you
get very different types of Dynamics I mean
she's not as strongly prevalent and Creed
too like she's there but you know like it
she was just like the wife you know um but
at least that's what I remember I don't remember
fiance yeah oh she's just a fiance in the
second one yeah he can get he proposed her
in the second one at the beginning I don't
I don't remember them actually getting I know
I just rewatched it but I don't remember seeing
them actually get married unless there was
a time Jump and I just it went over my head
but oh interesting okay well there was there
was either way but I love the evolution of
that I think Michael B Jordan knows his character
in and out of the one where he can direct
and do it and even on the dramatic like having
him behind the camera I think and then actually
removing Rocky gives the Creed World a little
bit of benefits to let other people like Duke
Duke Jr get it more of a chance to shine it
allows them even more scenes probably for
for Tessa Thompson because we're not having
the Rocky Relationships so I think removing
him does help and I feel like this did show
like oh you can't continue this without him
as weird as it is to say that I feel like
you you can do it and introducing the Jonathan
Majors character and and I feel like we are
kind of done with the Creed story at this
point yeah but it does also set it up in a
way where you know the Jonathan Majors character
had more story and you know back to the things
that I to be a little bit more specific of
what what I think we're sort of craving because
I feel like it was kind of General about it
you know when they're saying you know game
is out there [__] talking and you know
challenging this in your man I'm like we should
see that we should see that that trajectory
of how he's rising up in the boxing league
and all the [__] talking that he's doing
and then watching the build up to it um because
you spend so much with it with it not building
up to them fighting you just kind of know
they're gonna fight only because it's a Korean
movie so you know eventually they're gonna
fight but it was it's not until like an hour
in when the switch happens when you see you
know Jonathan majors and that confrontation
on the beach yeah and I think there there
should have been a little bit more of a build
up to it but other than that I I I I have
mad respect for the fact that this went a
different way and did not feel like a formulaic
like that's that's kind of where Cree too
fell in for me where I really love Creed one
I like Creed 2 but for the most part it was
like yeah this is like a rocky three and four
it's like a Rocky movie and this didn't feel
that way and I really loved it as someone
who's a big fan of the friend this franchise
I really loved how they took a different way
that was still very compelling um and a little
harsh I thought I thought this was a little
harsh and I love that so overall yeah I appreciated
the movie a lot I liked it a lot I would get
I would give it like uh beat beat boxing gloves
and 80 85 actually I'll give it like an 85.
pretty close to the Rotten Tomatoes what's
Rotten Tomatoes it got an 89 from the critics
okay I got a 96 from the fans nice I'm an
85. all right um it's good to hear back to
the future came out there your commando some
other good films what would you give it uh
probably go like 87 88 something like that
there you go that's why we have a percentage
thing instead of an eight out of ten thing
get some wiggle room here 8.7 but uh really
quickly last thing I just want to say if they
did have rocky in this film I thought possibly
again before seeing that he was not on the
IMDb list I thought maybe they were going
to go the route if he actually does pass away
and how that affects Adonis um I thought maybe
they were going to go that route but obviously
the whole drama that was behind the scenes
um but again I I thought what happened with
the mother and all that was really compelling
and pushing the the story forward and with
Adonis and all that so yeah and that's another
thing too is like without having Rocky we
we get a chance for that more that relationship
to shine I do think that not having Rocky
actually helped uh for a lot of it at the
same time there is that lingering question
of why isn't anyone acknowledging like where
is like what's going on Rocky in this movie
because what happened at the end of two he
went to see Robert and his grandson where
were they living I think I thought it was
Canada I don't remember I I don't know but
yeah maybe he's living with them now who knows
or he's still running Adrian's in Philadelphia
because yeah rocky rocky was such a big part
of his life of this whole career that is not
gonna think about it it does it does make
you go you think there will be like a phone
call or something if Rocky's still alive you
know yeah well Sylvester said he's never gonna
watch this movie ever uh I mean it it it it
goes down such a dark like the first two thirds
of this I think are so fantastic much they're
they're fantastic but they're so it's much
darker than anything before absolutely and
I and I don't feel like that's the association
that Rocky that's that Sylvester Stallone
likes would want for this franchise because
the other ones do always have like even though
Creed one and two are are darker than like
your Rocky movies the inspiring there's there
is still that rousing of the spirit to Vibe
you know and that that certain kind of heart
where this one does not quite do that and
I get where Sylvester's coming from but I
appreciate that I appreciated that about this
film it was different but it was still compelling
different but this is from the guy who I mean
it's funny to hear because like he still he
has the Rambo franchise which is like so dark
I've actually never seen those movies oh my
God Andrew they're the best I love every one
of them but yeah guys what do you think about
Cree 3 do you love it is it your favorite
was it the most crowd-pleasing entertainment
source of your life and how much do you disagree
with everything we said let us know uh yeah
let us know subscribe leave a like all we
can do is be honest still really like the
fighting and stuff but hey let's end this
with a
Michael B guess what you picked the right
guy you know why why this is the honestly
got truth Michael B the day we're shooting
this he uploaded his movie reaction for Creed
Three oh perfect timing so guys Michael B
Omni media who has guessed it on this Chanel
and yeah what are the I didn't even put that
together Michael B yeah what are the odds
um Omni media go watch I haven't seen his
reaction yet obviously but I'm sure it's good
he did the road to Crete three he watched
he did a reaction all the Rocky movies then
Creed movies Landing him at Creed Three and
so I do want to see his reaction for it because
it's been a quite a journey one of the best
reactors out there love you Michael I'm gonna
send you a text message right now saying I
love you show me photos of your belly I thought
he doesn't even send me messages like that
so you should feel very privileged ever since
you started going on that freaking Channel
that's true you feel like it's interesting
I have betrayed you and your trust you need
to understand this it's gonna take time to
get over the hurt we can settle it in the
ring in the meantime I'm gonna start messaging
Michael instead of you but don't forget I
did officiate your wedding so I got that over
Michael that's why this hurts even more what
I have to go through now we do need to go
to a boxing ring although it because of you
I'm starting to get a little more Jack so
you better be careful
it's the end of the video you might as well
give it a shot damn that's not bad man you're
still really firm do you take collagen what's
going on I do I don't take collagen ah so
I got that over you huh so if I take some
collagen to be a little more firm I'll give
you I just learn about what college it is
and I was like I should take some collagen
yeah peptides dude damn that's why you're
so that's why yeah cause I got a little bit
okay whatever go watch Omni medium foreign
[Music]